ataques rusos sobre infraestructura
civil este miércoles se reportaron
graves daños en un supermercado y un
edificio residencial en la ciudad
ucraniana de mykolaiv un presentimiento
salvó de la muerte a la familia de artem
silchenko
ayer queríamos volver a casa pasar la
noche pero de alguna manera nuestro
corazón nos dijo que teníamos que irnos
y salimos a tiempo salimos y luego todo
se vino abajo vi desde mi casa de campo
no tan lejos que todo brillaba boom boom
así
no es la primera vez que la familia se
sentó se ve afectada por los bombardeos
de las fuerzas invasoras el padre de
arte murió a causa de la angustia
provocada por los constantes ataques
lanza de donde no enterramos
recientemente acabábamos de renovar el
apartamento de mis padres para que
tuvieran una buena vida en la jubilación
solo mira esto ahora todo está en
cenizas las agresiones rusas a la ciudad
han sido casi constantes desde el
comienzo de la invasión los delitos en
general hay que decir que durante toda
la guerra sólo 21 días no estuvimos bajo
fuego un barcito en donde según el
alcalde al menos unos 131 civiles han
muerto en mykolaiv desde el 24 de
febrero
590 personas han resultado heridas se
estima que los daños materiales en esa
localidad ascienden a casi 700 58
millones de dólares